guys you're not gonna believe this but
people are outraged at something a
celebrity Gweneth Paltrow is challenging
herself to live on $29 a week roughly
the same amount each member of
low-income families on the Supplemental
Nutrition Assistance Program are
allotted what seems like noble
intentions are being met with AI roles
and mockery on social media after
posting a photo of her grocery haul
notorious for being rich and oblivious
Paltrow is being torn a new one on
social media for supposing a diet of
fresh veggies black beans and brown rice
is sufficient enough for hard-working
physically active people Mother Jones is
criticizing the actress by titling a
recent article one its outro confuses
her latest Master Cleanse with an
attempt to relate to the poor
notorious for being rich and oblivious I
think we editorialized that just a tiny
bit there but point taken now of course
we talk about this all-time outrage
everyone's outraged all the time I'm
outraged about everything constantly I'm
always looking for things to be outraged
by this seems to be one of those cases
where I think she's generally trying to
put good into the world and she they
love knocking her because she's pretty
and she's smart and whatever but she
said she steamed her bagina and she's
rich but she's the one that steamed her
vagina right didn't she steam her vagina
somebody somebody steamed yes the
steaming of a vagina she steamed a
vagina we'll do it like a post it's like
a poached vagina but you take it off a
little early but I it seems she's trying
to do something good here and by showing
how hard it is for people to live on
snap and by the way 28 bucks for a week
how is that even remotely considered but
what do you first let's just talk about
the outrage what do you think about all
the people that then just attack people
are looking for something to yell about
because one of the last time any of
those [ __ ] talked about snap
yeah ever in life when was the last time
the any of these entitled [ __ ] who
weren't living on $20 or $29 a week
yeah ever talked about it use their
social media platform and their voices
to actually bring awareness to the fact
that it's too little money and people
can't get good nutrition on it where is
she she may be a little bit idealistic
I'm yeah okay they need a little bit
more rice and something to keep them
feeling full from passing out yes you
can pass out cuz you have a bunch of
assistants to catch you but you know I
get I get it
not maybe the ideal but look at the
intention sometimes I don't focus on the
execution yeah what is that about the
obsession to ignore the intention which
is obviously good if she wanted
publicity she could have done a
gajillion other things beyond trying to
bring attention to snap which most
people don't care about what you said I
mean people just want to be outraged
about something so they're gonna look
past your intentions and see the food
that she bought and say oh look this is
a Master Cleanse this isn't food this
isn't carbs people who are low income
around working you know strenuous jobs
and stuff and they need more energy and
carbs to you know produce that energy
and a bunch of leafy vegetables and
garlic and I don't know eggs whatever
she had isn't exactly enough substance
for most people but I mean overall like
you said she's doing a good thing she's
trying to reach out and spread awareness
about something that she thought was
important and instead of like looking at
that and being like okay you know maybe
you didn't do the best job but I see
what you're trying to do I hear you
let's just focus on the problem and you
know help here's a link to donate people
if you want it you know help them out
instead of focusing so much than what
she's doing wrong why don't you focus on
the problem that she's actually trying
to solve so getting over the outrage
portion of this thing 29 bucks a week my
math isn't great but 29 divided by 7
days a week is a foreign change is there
any way you could possibly survive on
four dollars and change a day over the
course of a week there's another aspect
to what what did when it's shopping list
to do which is maybe kind of maybe would
have been inspired if they were on
Twitter I mean they probably work in a
job let's keep it real people on snap
ding got time to be hustling so maybe
maybe that they didn't get the message
but maybe all of this talk about it
would make them think they could buy
more vegetables and let's crap even
though truthfully speaking it's harder
to eat healthy yeah a smaller budget
than it is to eat a bunch of crap yeah
you know people always say that and I've
gotten [ __ ] for this before but
sometimes it seems to me you could if
you went to Trader Joe's obviously not a
particularly high-end thing I get it's
not everywhere but you could get a
things and some peanut butter and beans
about but nobody wants to live like that
no nobody wants to look like that number
one my point is that happy meal at
McDonald's or whatever it's called is a
lot more expensive than actually like
you could get maybe four of those for 28
when you can actually get some better
ingredients
for cheaper it's still a challenge I
mean 20 if you really think about what
when I go into the grocery store just to
pick up a couple things yeah I spent $30
I'll go in fro and I get like three
things that's because I want to buy
organic eggs and that you know all of
the things that are better for you and
aren't necessarily as genetic
genetically modified or asked you know I
mean it's like even as generic a lot of
like know pretty much everything it's
the program is severely underfunded
clearly because people anything this is
what I hope this is for one person or a
family right no this is for a family of
four for a familya bunch of leafy
vegetables and stuff in it like that
wouldn't be enough for most individuals
much less right but they should be more
angry that they're asking for people to
survive on them so is that so is that
the crutches right so is that the crux
is that the system sort of can't get
fixed because even though now so we you
know the media calls a little bit
tension to this people go alright 28
bucks clearly not enough for one person
much less for people but those people on
the bottom they don't vote as much as
the people up top they don't have access
to voting all that stuff it's a whole
other topic but so there's never the
system never has an incentive to to fix
the problem so is that really the
problem here it's not about the what you
can buy with the money right yeah I mean
definitely we need to do different
things to fix the problem a lot people
like to focus on the external issues and
just the media hype of it but I mean
it's obviously a real problem I don't
understand how one person could survive
off that much less of families that have
been channeled into getting that program
fixed as opposed to a chronic Paltrow
who's just shedding light on something
she's doing she's still doing something
more than you are right government her
Wow
all right well there you go Gweneth you
know everyone's hating on you all the
time but we are all down with what
you're doing anyway what do you guys
think could you possibly survive on $28
a week just for yourself
much less for a family of four let us
know in the comments